this is our first viewing of the spirit
and it early yeah I haven't seen this
movie I I heard things a lot of not good
things I'm a huge fan of the Sin City
movies both of them I hear they're like
not that I love the second one I don't
know why people went yeah I love them
but I hear this is trying to be Sin City
and fails really hard at it and it's
anything but the spirit I have not read
the spirit I don't know much about it at
have you do you know I know it's like a
classic count I don't know Jax I don't
know anything about it something about
Samuel Jackson dressed as a Nazi and I
am so curious to see how that happened I
just I haven't heard a person yet that
likes this movie so let's let's see if
we like it maybe we will sure strange
things available
I won't prejudge movies I am death death
is gonna hang and you shall have a queen
worship me in despair Christ that's
gorgeous oh it looks so good
please don't sigh maybe we'll get a good
one that maybe people were wrong Doug
how many movies are out there that look
good but no most of them had a lot of
movies who knows how far is tentacle
spread and it's Judson City it's the
exact same style there is no difference
within broke keep banishing it again and
again till it does break up it ain't the
spirit don't make the spirit
how do you launch facedown with your
fists extended and then land then your
feet should be sticking up like this
like Wiley coyote I'm spirit doesn't
sound that cool
I'm spirit man I bet you know what I'm
Batman yeah I'm just Batman can't get
danny elfman well David Newman will
write Batman for you how big octopus big
yeah really show every major villain
yeah
even spider-man too freaking spider-man
too new to call him Doc Ock nod keep
calling him octopus if only I've got my
motherfucking medical degree I could be
a doc I see mollusk you speak it
motherfucker
take this you nut cracker plant not even
remotely fun to watch that's what I
thought just like this should be amazing
you imagine if like a Sam Raimi or
Tarantino did this I just don't know
anything about these fucking people Tim
Burton's baman you got that one scene
where you beat show that guys like I'm
Batman but short is quick it is a
character like well we've boom what 15
minutes on this and I'm just like all
I've learned is like okay they're all
invincible I'm gonna be the guy who's
always talking against you this is like
every cliche with like nothing new added
even the visual style is just Sin City
there's nothing new this came out the
same here is Dark Knight I think that's
sad yeah someone else did Barrett Dark
Knight's story then the guy that made
dark oh shit we're in Newsies who drives
with the window just slightly cracked in
the arm and I just like to brag look at
the diamonds
peebs it makes me real like this would
work if you did get like a worn baby to
direct it and do like a Dick Tracy or
something like that like really create
this different world but it's like it's
just insane all I'm thinking is this is
Sin City worse be honest no Dick Tracy's
a little on the dolls no no but but at
least it's like it's its own world this
is clearly just like a Dick Tracy type
story but being told like Sin City and
those are still two very different
things I say we had a solid man without
snow oh we're back okay
one way this locket ended up in poor
Sussex and she was there she was wearing
it she is implicated that's something
like a song see yeah go to a song - it
gets located the spirits got a rumble
tonight other box you fart stinky smell
dummied re poopy head something's gonna
be explained eventually right anything
did he have those to begin with watch it
it's just a poor man's Tarantino hey
Kill Bill was cool let's do that shit
and by the way the lack of gore and this
is driving me nuts yeah that's a good
point there he g13 that's its fucking
pg-13 fuck pg-13 that's part of the
appeal of Frank Miller's that you're
gonna see something over-the-top
ridiculous gory and stuff and if we
don't even get that I don't even know
why they're attracted to each other like
really think about I don't know a thing
about them why am I like who their
chemistry okay that was awesome that's
the first fucking awesome thing in this
movie
he's like the city needs me it's always
Craig who hoppy the bass
yes needs me oh oh fuck really like
using the word fart in this I think he's
the only guy I'm enjoying watching
actually he's always good right there I
knew my old man would never be the same
again
I recognize that ass - it's so much shit
about this dude I know he likes women
that's it I think he's more concerned
about the city cuz he wants to hump it I
just love all its tunnels and crevices
and plumbing
weird yes sir what is going on I feel
like we're in spy kids all of a sudden
yeah is this where they get their thumb
people in those movie how could I get
anything done with all this time on my
hands maybe time on your hands how long
does it take just to get to those
costumes we're supposed to be worth
something more than jewels something a
little girl's dreams are made Oh Pony
cellphones ya know they say there's like
online and stuff like that so like none
of this really connects I'm coming after
you octopus but before I kill you you're
gonna ask me some questions
Who am I talkin to question 1 question 2
where am I going
question 3 what am I gonna land on boom
I'm giving pavement that's a total
pickle idea oh I lost my Boy Scout I
lost my little prom queen creepy here
all right what's her story
what's any of their story but why is
death just show up everyone's Mangala
trying to like the camera why does this
one have lady death but infinity war
does not some pretty strange are you
looking at us now what is that here's
monologuing before and now he's talking
a lot like did nothing matches nothing's
consistent fucking told you I told you
man though now at this point it's
actually not surprising springtime for
mother fucking hell Scarlett Johansson
just looks like she's singing they're
dead I just like no one will remember
this also is that a fucking cronut on
the catering table there's Wolfenstein
3d only the D stands for dome I'm a
black Nazi and you're a white badass
we're obviously paradoxes
might as well go into some backstory and
character now well not character just
backstory why don't you open with him
busting from the grave yeah not a
perfect place to open the fucking movie
still breathe it's impossible but I'm
still alive
damn monkey paw muffin is the only
character I have any concern for right
now I know you better
oh you bad fuck up muffin she is all the
reason I need I will kill you please let
that be his battle cry from now on
everything start to make sense I don't
think that no no no absolutely one I
yeah it's too late for that
you could have Stephen Hawking come in
and try to explain this shit and it's
not gonna happen yeah okay all right you
get one bonus point for that this is the
weirdest version of inglorious basterds
I've ever seen it was already pretty
weird you know spirits kind of a dumb
ass the more I think about he hasn't
done that much most of it's just him get
his ass whupped Lorelai you're not true
me just yet
no you know what it is it's like every
woman he comes across he belongs and
there's just like I don't need you Frank
know about this yeah
oh no the movies starting over glad it's
not like freezing out otherwise you know
she would be ridiculous wearing a skimpy
outfit like that but both of them wore
their essential high heels why is every
person when they open a trunk they have
to do this in a movie you ever notice
that like they have to rub it down first
it's really weird what is human is he
asking Frank Miller that I got eight of
everything oh is that way cuz there's
clearly lots of times where he does not
have eight of everything does he have
eight Nazi outfits eight samurai outfits
eight hymns now that he can clone does
he have eight muffins
let's die yeah that's
where I'm at right now maybe I'll wear
it now and then but it doesn't mean I'm
a girl I would have it no other way
I'm like 81 and I'm like the octopus I
have like eight women but the octopus
didn't even have any women do you have a
baby was on my heart
that's not your head baby found his dick
haha she is the love of my life
she is my city
you're the deadbeat dad you're a
terrible person yeah I like how massage
is easy she's mine and mine alone unlike
all the other woman who get to share me
fuck was that that was so stupid
I don't I don't even know what I just
saw yeah man the dialogue was just
garbage but the thing is it's like I
can't tell if it's supposed to be funny
or now because it's not funny enough
spirit man the serious live action tick
I guess the spirit was willing but the
flesh was weak stupid
you